katia bonjour alors le point sur cette
réunion est ce qu'elle a commencé
d'ailleurs là en fait il s'agit de
plusieurs réunions un tour à tour les
syndicats vont défiler donc il faut est
sortie de réunion le syndicat alliance
vient juste d'entrer
évidemment cette ces réunions avons
tenir vont se tenir aujourd'hui et
demain car les policiers et les
syndicats sont extrêmement en colère
après les propos du ministre l'intérieur
qui sauf qu'un scanner lundi notamment
sur une série de mesures annoncées alors
la première c'est celle de l'abandon de
la prise par le cou dit d'étranglement
vous savez qu'elle est controversée car
elle a causé la mort de certains
interpellés dans le monde y compris en
france
or les policiers estiment que c'est une
prise qui fait ses preuves qui est bonne
pour certains cas de figure et qu'il n'a
pas été donnée d'alternative donc il
s'oppose formellement à cette mesure
ils se sentent donc abandonné contesté
estime qu on n'a pas tenu compte de
leurs points de vue je vous propose
d'écouter le secrétaire général du
syndicat alliance à ce propos
aujourd'hui le gouvernement parce que
c'est trop facile de citer monsieur
castaner il ya monsieur questionnaire et
tous les autres c'est ça le souci c'est
parce que au dessus de monsieur castagna
monsieur macron et là c'est important de
le signaler aujourd'hui il n'ya pas sa
police alors il va faire deux choix à ce
gouvernement
soyez va la soutenir ils qui va
l'annoncer soit ils risquent de subir la
colère des policiers notamment parce que
eux ils sont professionnels
il n'arrête pas de travailler h 24 ça
fait un an et demi qui subissent des
violences au quotidien aussi notamment à
travers les manifestations qu'on connaît
des gilet jaune
deux choses la première c'est que la
technique d'intervention ne soit plus
interdit mais reviennent
pourquoi parce que les collègues
forcément en sont démunis et ne pourront
pu neutraliser l'individu s'ils
souhaitent l'interpeller deuxième chose
une commission de travail afin de
trouver peut-être une autre technique
mais tant que cette technique n'est pas
trouvée gares dont celle ci parce que
les collègues en ont foncièrement
besoins et la deuxième chose qui est
tout aussi importante dire une bonne
fois pour toutes que la police n'est pas
raciste
la police a l'air républicaine et que le
mit l'intérieur soutient sa police mais
aussi que le président de la république
soutient sa police
doi autre chose avait fâché les
policiers dans les propos de christophe
castaner donc là tant les relater les
rentes zéro vis-à-vis du racisme et
évidemment ça ce n'était même pas ça qui
était contesté c'était plutôt des formes
d'accusation une défiance qu'ils ont
ressenti de la part du ministre avec ce
mot cette c'est plutôt ces termes
énigmatique qui était la suspension en
cas de soupçons avérés de d'actes de
propos racistes donc il y avait des
aspects contradictoires dans cette
phrase est bien yves lefebvre de du
syndicat fo qui sortait juste de réunion
a dit que christophe castaner durant
leurs échanges a estimé qu'il avait fait
une erreur ce qui signifie que les
procédures habituelles vont vont
peut-être être appliquées sans
changement en tout cas nous ferons un
point tout à l'heure quand nous en
saurons plus
surtout que cette décision sera prise à
la suite de toutes les réunions en tout
cas yves lefebvre du du syndicat fo a
expliqué qu'il appelait tous ses
collègues dans les commissariats à
déposer les menottes pour marquer leur
révolte et leur sentiment d'abandon de
face au pouvoir et non pas juste aux
ministres mais au pouvoir en général qui
les a envoyés au front durant de longs
mois lors de tous les épisodes de
contestation sociale
merci beaucoup katia pique nique pour
toutes ces précisions et à tout à
l'heure donc pour un nouveau point